you talked about room 104 earlier i
think you wrote like a spec script or
you did something
and now you're actually working with the
duploss brothers
yeah you talk about that yeah um so
when i was starting to make films uh the
duplass brothers were idols of mine
i thought the puffy chair was one of the
the greatest micro budget films ever
made i still think it's one of the best
um and i had really wanted to work with
them and i really wanted to
try to see a little bit more about how
they make stuff
so about this this story goes back quite
a ways actually about 10 years ago
uh the duplast brothers made a film in
maine though it was called blackrock
and if uh mark duvlass's wife katie was
the director
and kate bosworth was in it and like
bell was in it it was a thriller
yes okay really really great film and
when they came to maine they didn't have
any local crew
so the producer of the movie uh my
friend adela
she contacted me because i was living in
connecticut at the time and she said do
you know anybody that would want to come
up and work on this film
and i got her about a third of her crew
so
i as a benefit of that i got to go up
for a couple days
and i'd hang out with them for a weekend
as they were shooting and when i went
there mark was there
so i actually got to meet him when we
were on set
and absolutely like fanboy the whole
time
like had a hard time speaking to him but
he couldn't been cooler couldn't have
been nicer
and so we stayed in touch so fast
forward
you know eight nine years when i moved
out to los angeles
i ran into him at an event for the hbo
show animals that they had
and i went to go see the first couple
episodes of that and
i saw him work there and i told him you
know i'm in la now
you know i'm working in orange county so
that was great
um and then a couple months later he
actually cast me in an episode of the
first season of room 104.
oh my gosh yes um the show ultimately
cut my part out of the episode so it
didn't make the air
but when i was there i got to meet you
know the director of the episode
obviously and all the producers and then
that was sort of my first exposure to
the folks that were running their
company
so fast forward again now i'm in at csun
i have to do an internship in order to
graduate so
i contacted mark and i said hey is there
any way that i can work for you it'd be
great to
to be a part of the team and he said
yeah we actually started a short form
production company
it's called donut and they make
commercials they make branded content
they make interactive television
they make all sorts of stuff and they
need help
so i started interning with them and we
worked on
a number of uh non-scripted stuff series
and a couple
scripted series uh back in december of
last year
um i was helping them with like the
development of their interactive tv
shows
one of which is going to shoot later
this year i was an associate producer on
a web series that they made
so really got a chance to work with them
a lot
and that culminated after right after i
graduated in may
they're making a new movie and they
offered me to work
with them as a production assistant so
here i am 42 years old
uh the oldest production assistant in
los angeles
and i spent a month working with them
helping them make this film
and it was an amazing experience
it was really really great i can't give
any details about the movie itself
but being able to work with them and
seeing the folks that they work with
and how calm everything was on set and
just how they work with great people
that's the secret to their success i
think
is they just have so many wonderful
people in their ecosystem
that it's it's just awesome so it was it
was a really great experience and i hope
to
to keep working with them on stuff in
the future yeah they're very personable
and they have a great sense of humor
too it's not like it's just when the
camera's on they they right
they're able to laugh and just yeah
they're just they're salt of the earth
guys they really are
and it's interesting how a different
little like what would seem like small
opportunities that some people could
just say
oh well i don't know if i really want to
do this is now turned in
it just shows you if you kind of stay
the course how someone can notice you
it's so important
and the other thing to remember too is
that you know tied into that it's it's a
long game
you know you can't come into something
expecting someone to help you
if you don't help them first and you
know the fact that i got the opportunity
to pa on this movie
because i interned for them because i
gave them my time
and obviously it was a benefit to me
because i was able to work with some
great people
but they were able to do more as a
result of me being there
and had i not been there so that there's
there's a sort of turnabout for that you
know and then they offer me an
opportunity on a movie
you know that's that's how this works
you know people help each other
that's how you get ahead so you know my
hope is you know if they have another
movie in the future
maybe they might ask me to do something
you know in another role maybe a little
bigger role because i've shown them
you know i think i did a pretty okay job
you know as a pa
and you know we'll see where it goes do
you see that with some of the students
because things are so fast-paced whether
it's breaking news
i mean it almost the 24-hour news cycle
is no longer it's now like
it's yeah the two-hour news cycle and
then we've moved on to some new
horrible tragedy do you think a lot of
younger people they don't realize that
things still do take a while
because it seems like some people they
want this instant thing and maybe that's
just
youth they don't realize that things do
take some time
i think yeah i think youth is a big part
of it you know what is it mark twain had
that great quote i wish i could be 21
again when i knew everything
that i think that's i think it's an
important growth step
you know for young people to realize
that there are dues to pay
now how you pay them is an open question
um you know some folks they they
immediately
you know go out and start making their
own films and if they find success
that's great but there's a possible
caveat that they don't have the full
understanding of what it is that they're
doing if they get success early
if that makes sense yeah and then
there's other folks you know
they come in and they start at the
bottom and they work their way up and if
they find success then
they have a little bit of a different
viewpoint because they understand the
different people that are involved in
something
and what it takes to get to a particular
position
so in my experience the students who
get into something and start working
their way up
they have more of a respect for the
entire process and what everyone does
and i i tend to find that those folks
are a little more
knowledgeable about the entire
filmmaking process
um and i think they're a little more
grateful for
should they find success that they had
worked their way
towards it some film students of mine
they had gotten out of school and
through resources of their family they
get an opportunity to make a film
and they make the film and you know if
it finds success that's great
i feel like they miss a little bit not
having an opportunity to
you know to work some of those jobs and
understand what it's like looking from
the bottom
and you don't have to do it forever you
learn a lot on one film
you know even if it's just one you know
you get a sense of
what everybody's doing and how important
every person is
um there's a different viewpoint after
you do that um
it's not so much you know i'm hiring you
to do this it's it's i understand
how you play a small part in the whole
of making this movie
um so i think yeah i think that's that's
something that kids learn
eventually our age definitely has
something to do with it you know the
the instant news cycle is definitely
something that that reinforces the
instant gratification
and the lack of attention span uh that's
that's something that doesn't help
a mindset like that um
but you know i think most of the time
this town is
pretty solid in their attitude that you
need to start at the bottom if you want
to get anywhere
so i think i think la sort of brow beats
folks
you know into that kind of that kind of
path i think
you